most of you probably know that eric
trump is not exactly the one we
typically refer to as
the smart one but he even outdid himself
in a completely wacky interview
on abc on sunday with jonathan carl now
eric trump was interviewed i guess as a
surrogate of the trump administration or
a surrogate of the trump campaign i
think better said fine
but as you watch this i want you to
understand and consider
that the importance of beating trump
this election this november
it's not just about preventing trump
from being president for another four
years
so that the country doesn't go
completely off a cliff another reason
why
we must defeat trump this november is
that if we don't
in 2024 i guarantee it
either eric or don jr or ivanka are
going to have a leg up
in the republican primary for president
in 2024.
at some point one of them runs and i
believe that if trump gets another four
years
you will see at least the possibility of
an attempt at one of his kids running
and this interview should be a reminder
as to why we need to stop that
at absolutely all costs we know that the
republican electorate is really
ignorant they aren't going to stop the
trump kids so
we need to prevent them from getting a
running start by trump getting another
four years in november so let's get into
the clips
eric trump on this week uh again
you know he's supposedly just a
businessman at this point
but he's there as a surrogate of the
trump campaign doesn't really make sense
but he's there and he is
mad that the media will accurately
report
when trump does these mass rallies it
risks spreading the virus take a look at
this
i mean they took every precaution again
temperature checks mass they were
outside
it was a beautiful event um sure but why
is it that it's only trump events that
are called that
why why are these protests that we see
all over the place i see them in new
york i see them in portland i see them
in seattle
i see them everywhere antifa is going
wild and no one ever talks about them
wearing masks but yet a beautiful
protest by african americans and
hispanic americans
in front of the white house to support
our incredible men and women
in law enforcement becomes the subject
of an abc
show at 9 00 a.m on a sunday morning i
mean it
well well eric eric to to be clear i'm
not i've been i've lost a lot of faith
in the media john i really have
well eric to be clear i'm not
criticizing and i'm reporting
the fact he's totally incoherent what is
he even talking about
these mass events do have the potential
to be super spreader events
period and the fact that the media is
covering them as such
is because the media is doing a good job
of course he's not pleased with it
eric trump then admits that trump is
having rallies at the white house now
this is problematic for two reasons
trump has been playing coy and saying
these are peaceful protests because if
you call it a protest it's okay
if you call it a rally it's a problem
but it's also a problem because you're
not supposed to use
the white house for political
campaigning
and by calling it a rally eric trump
again
nobody said maybe he says i've never
claimed eric trump is the smart one
but he's admitting that these are
rallies at the white house everybody and
you know this you report from there
every single day everybody that goes
within uh you know 500 yards of the the
white house is tested every single day
and it's a little bit of a different
apparatus
you know in in that machine but again i
just find it i find the hypocrisy so
crazy i mean you go out there and you
see these massive
massive riots and protests in these
liberal-run cities and no one's wearing
masks and no one cares no one cares
the media doesn't talk about them i mean
how many have we had in new york and how
many have we had in chicago and all
these things and
the media never talks about that but
again when you have a peaceful trump
you know rally at the white house in
support of law enforcement by african
americans cnn cuts away
you know msnbc cuts away from those
events they don't truly the rantings of
someone completely disconnected from
reality he really seems to think
that he and his family are just the
biggest victims out there
they're martyrs they've agreed to be the
first family
to you know despite what would be best
for them in order to just make things
better for everybody and everybody
attacks them of course
the big differences include that
everyone is wearing masks
at the various protests that's why they
don't seem to have spread the virus
eric trump who is clearly not an expert
in any of these matters then goes on to
talk about donald trump
taking a vaccine now it's false that
as far as we know trump didn't get a
vaccine
during his treatment for coronavirus he
got medications
but not vaccines and certainly donald
trump has done nothing
in terms of creating a vaccine but eric
trump bizarrely says here
donald trump took a vaccine and the
interviewer
jonathan carl can't believe what he's
hearing take a listen to this
the guy sounded 100 it was amazing it
actually probably goes to speak to how
good some of these vaccines that are
being created are and
what my father's done on the vaccine
front no one could have done no one
could have done i mean
literally maidan was calling my father
xenophobic for shutting down
america from from travel to china i mean
and the virus came from china
my father literally started day one
creating this vaccine he
worked to push this vaccine and now my
father just took it
and uh you see how well he got over it
wait wait can you i think he's an
inspiration i think
as american jean we should be very proud
of that can you clarify that you said
your father just took a vaccine
meaning when he was in walter reed the
medicines that he was taking in
the therapeutic he felt horrible and and
on
on saturday again i spoke to the man
three times on saturday and he sounded
tremendous and i think it goes to show
the power
of you know medicine and um in this
country and how far that you know
that we've come on covid in the last uh
you know six seven months
vaccines cured my dad
which my dad created despite
joe biden being xenophobic what
what my father took a vaccine
huh what does it make any sense
is eric trump now there's a there's one
idea which is
eric trump let slip that trump has
received a vaccine but they're not going
public
i just think eric trump's dumb i don't
think he's letting anything slip here
eric trump then was asked about the fact
that donald trump called kamala harris a
monster
and eric trump of course defends it this
is funny a vice president pence when he
debated kamala harris he said it was a
privilege to be on the stage with her uh
recognized her
history making uh pick as as biden's
running mate
and then the next day your father said
that she was a monster
what why yeah how how is kamal harris a
monster why why did he say that well you
know i think there are a lot of the
stances that she takes that are just
they're they're mind-boggling to me i
mean she's come out and she's called to
abolish law enforcement she's you know
compared
members of of ice to the kkk in a
congressional hearing
she wants to take away 180 million
private health care plans in in this
country um last week she was coming out
talking about how she literally
she wanted to limit the amount of red
meat that americans could eat i mean i
would
but but eric but eric eric eric
political differences and i think you've
mischaracterized
her positions in that litany but
political differences are one thing
a monster you're calling the democratic
vice presidential nominee a monster your
father did
how is that i mean i i don't get it
john you know you're also dealing with a
person who's willing to lie every single
day you know it's amazing one day
you know they're calling for the let's
kamala harris and frankly joe biden but
i love that when eric trump says you're
dealing with someone who's willing to
lie every day jonathan carl says who
it's a completely kafka-esque moment
that's not i don't know that we've ever
used the term kafka-esque
on this program before it is a
completely surreal kafka-esque moment
eric when eric says you're dealing with
someone who's willing to lie every day
jonathan carl is confused because
there's no bigger liar in politics right
now than donald trump
i guess eric was talking about joe biden
or kamala harris but a completely
wild moment also he's lying by saying
kamala wants to abolish police that's
hilarious she doesn't in fact
people are some people on the left don't
like kamala because she doesn't want to
abolish police
she doesn't want to take anybody's
health care and then eric trump
ends this interview which didn't go well
claiming that it's a lie that we know
who all of donald trump's creditors are
and you can tell he's particularly
triggered by this one because he starts
speed talking
and making even less sense than he had
been making throughout the interview
the media has become the the activist
arm for the democratic party
eric nothing's fair eric we're eric
we're asking we're asking legitimate
questions one last one
the new york times report also uh said
that the president
owes some 400 million dollars uh don't
the american people have a right to know
who he is indebted to who the president
of the united states owes money to can
you clarify that for us
jonathan is financial disclosures you
know exactly who the money is owed to
that's
that's another democratic talking point
that you just you know exactly who the
money is okay
my father i own billions of dollars and
and on a proportion of his net worth my
father has very very very low leverage
in fact the new york times if you want
to bring them into this
they came out and said that the other
day if you own if you own buildings if
you own real estate you you carry some
debt that's
that's what developers do that's what
business owners do they carry some debt
now as a proportion of his net worth
it's incredibly low we have a phenomenal
company but there's there's nothing new
about that and by the way it's the same
debt that he got elected on
and it's all fully disclosed as
financial disclosure forms
government that you have access to eric
eric thank you for joining us i
appreciate your time on this sunday
morning thank you
we have a phenomenal company he says
that lost money so that we could get
tax breaks but it's a great company it
just happens to be in direct conflict
with what we learn about the
profitability of the company
through the bombshell new york tax
report new york times tax report which
said
the business actually was a disaster
many years
painful to listen to and again he's
there eric trump is as a surrogate for
the campaign
although he supposedly has no role in
anything government or campaign related
he's merely an independent businessman
can you make any more sense out of it
than i can and do you agree with me
that of the three adult trump children
ivanka don jr and eric
eric's by far the worst in these
interviews let me know if you agree
disagree
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful lucy offers a nicotine
gum in three flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate
they also have lozenges which come in
cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online from countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get
20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical